What do I do if I get a tick bite? We go out often in the summer and the kids
And often come home with ticks is there something I should do
So yeah, there is something you should do
You can't you know different parts of the country. You're going to pick up ticks. We get ticks
I get pull off at least a dozen or two ticks off of my body every summer where we live
So I won't sign a lot, you know, it's it's just a part of nature
Number one is to not be, you know, fearful of ticks. So can ticks
spread disease? Yes, can certain ticks, especially the deer tick, have be more prone to sped to spread a tick related
illness
Yes, can we test those ticks for an illness for if that tick itself has line disease?
Yes, we can't but there's different labs that can so if you have a tick that's adhered to you or your loved one if you take that tick off
It can be wise to put it on a piece of tape so that you preserve the tick or the tick will die
But you preserve the tick to have it tested if you have concerns for
tick-borne illness so some signs of line disease and you or your loved one
Would be the feeling of illness typically flu-like stuff
also if you look on our
our site my hope for lime I go into details of what a what a tick
rash looks like a bullseye rash
It's looks very different than just a rash a stout just red spot. It's literally it looks like a bullseye
But it's only a small percentage of people that get that bullseye rash if you get a tick bite on your head and you pull the tick off your head
Very slim chance. It's you're going to see any type of bullseye rash
So how do you know if you have a lime disease or not? I took this tick off me. It was a really small tick
I looked at it on the internet. It's definitely a deer tick. How do I know if it has lime or not? What should I do?
Well, I
Think you need to watch symptoms now understand just because you got a bacterial infection
Doesn't mean that you need to go get a data biotic
Your body can fight off a bacterium and if your body is fighting off bacteria on a daily basis
You just don't know what there is a way to know it is because your body is winning your real system is destroying the bacteria
And if you're you're not don't have to worry about it, but it's when
That bacterial infection starts to reproduce to the point where it's making you sick that you might need some aid
And if it is burrelia
Burrenorphi, which is the bacteria
Involved with lime disease. I highly recommend you get an antibiotic because you don't want that
That's a very dusty bacteria. You don't want it to go crazy and to move it to chronic lime disease
So having some antibiotic said your whole talking to a lime literate medical doctor that can prescribe antibiotics
Having somebody in your pocket if you're in an area where you get a lot of ticks that you should have a relationship
with a lime literate doctor so that you can
Get a prescription that you can have
Possibly on file. So if this happens to you and the weekend and your
Child is throwing up flu-like symptoms in the middle of the summer. This is odd
Nobody else is sick in the house. We took a tick off them. It looked like a deer tick
And you know, what is going on? I think you're I can't prescribe, but I would say you're better off
Safe than sorry and taking it antibiotic. I wonder if you're going to take an antibiotic. I always take probiotic with it
It'll help to finish the negative effects of the antibiotic, but you're you're better off safe than sorry in that
And dealing with any gut issues afterwards. Those are all correctable
But it's hard to correct it hard to deal with chronic lime
So you're better off taking an antibiotic. Usually it's going to knock it out completely
That's one of the ways you'd know that if it's some viral flu
Take it antibiotic. It doesn't do anything
So if it makes the person's symptoms better
Many times after just one dose if you're not used to take it a lot of antibiotics
You're going to have a better response to it and
It can you know that say you should just state a one dose, but that's how you know what's a bacterial infection. So
highly recommend that so
Yeah, ticks and tick-borne illnesses are real. They're dangerous and they can ruin a person's life
In a lot of ways they're responsible
For creating and stimulating the body to cause all sorts of inflammatory processes
microglial primate
autoimmune conditions and
They're nasty. So if you could dip it in the bud, you're much better off
Many times in a person, you know, the difficult thing is is the person may have
um
The symptoms of all a tick-borne
Disease in the summertime when ticks are present and you they never find a tick. So what do you do then?
Well, if you're in if you're outside and you're exposed to ticks and you some the nips of the
Deertick are so small that you may never find it and you don't get a
rash
It's difficult because if you're going to go into a doctor and get a Lyme test by the time that
Lab comes back
Positive or negative you that may have already moved into the chronic phase. So I think a good
literate medical doctor would prescribe based upon signs and symptoms
Not solely based upon objective lab tests
In the case of a possible Lyme. I think that's that's an appropriate and um wise
Doctor that you're dealing with they're looking at okay, you are outside you're hiking this all came about nobody
Also the family has this your fever spiked you got you know, you're feeling ill you got shakes your
What's put you on a bag for a couple days if it knocks it down that we know what's a bacterial or other right track
If it doesn't then maybe discontinue it and you know eat a lot chicken soup and you know
Take a bunch of immune stimulants to overcome this and and that's the right thing to do
So you just got to you don't always just treat you know based upon one test
You treat based upon a differential diagnosis based upon subjective and objective findings
That you gathered from the patients you're making a clinical
Assessment based upon that too often we are now
Living in a world where doctors are simply technicians that um are governed by you know drug companies and um
They can't make those kind of decisions anymore unfortunately, so you got to find the doctor prior to this